hello and to welcome to this video
playing cast or grin monster schwa I
think not sure and probably not
schreuder right schreuder I'm sorry from
Chile yeah I have a very bad score
against him one out of five from many
better positions and winning positions
and what not and okay this is a somewhat
strange opening line Knight f6 I don't I
don't understand anything here and we're
not just basically winning here what
what is happening here before 93
okay let's think about it before 93
Quincy one Quincy one night before takes
takes bishop to tune so in all of those
five games and winning positions all of
them and this is the next one we have a
winning position I hope I'd have win
this time always night before still
somewhat playable okay so b5 immediately
yeah I think castles actually
so c 60 is that too early hmm I know
everything looks good I should be
reasonably quick quite a number of those
games are lost on time so this is why
I'm stating this um okay um c6
I don't know this is also pretty good
so Bishop a from 125 this f6 you should
not Queen damage with a it's just about
it works okay if I go Bishop f1 Bishop
f8 this still might be might be okay for
him I'm taking too long here again the
ambition if 8 ticking actually doesn't
make much sense what
I'm kind of letting this slip away a
little bit feels like it'll at least
maybe not maybe not the bishops chest
maybe was possible
you should have 6 48 wins and Bishop the
195 also wins I think Queen the one
maybe
I can just take that 2151
so what is think about this for a moment
rope t8 is six
pa then isn't that a piece route to a
droopy and it's it's a piece Jack rookie
6 also was possible I saw that but I
thought this is clearer check hi morning
black resign yes that's important i
really hate to lose every game from
winning positions against us player even
though i think i probably screwed it up
yeah here black and all night Knight f6
is a move I don't know I think usually
black plays d 4 in this position I
thought it is the only move and this
this I never I never saw and well here
okay a 394 I was actually unsure if not
takes before might be possible night a 2
is a move oh I didn't see that one buddy
and black is still in the game very much
so so then maybe I had to do something
else there Brooksie one is what the
engine gives with a cleared
hmm ok well the way it went I should
just win just like that so here this is
this how do i how do I win this Quincy 3
is still engine approves up to here I am
and now it wants to go see six yeah I
was never sure if I should play this
move or not yeah I didn't but computer
is unsure know it gives my move look
everyone this Bishop Bishop f1 is the
engines suggestion and again then c6
coming yeah this is not so great i guess
this but now Queen f4 is good according
to the comp ok I took it just interested
in this yeah until Quincy 7 is supposed
to be played this losers right yeah it
loses to tonight 25 Jack so that was
correct Oh Bishop e3 was winning
immediately but i hope this also right
yeah there's also wins that's good yeah
so a couple of things here I can take it
and just win by material he cannot take
the Queen due to the pin so this
wouldn't work if it takes with the
bishop I have this and this is made next
if it takes with the Queen or Bishop e7
is given by the engine but I thought I
just take him and I win I'll also we're
nearby material
so then this is a win NTM Luke g8 Bishop
takes takes takes and yeah I rookie 6
also was possible they both should win
yeah but that's what this is very clean
because i'm a daddy's and block the file
the with the night stopping the sea porn
and here we resigned okay i'm happy
about this one only had a couple of bad
games against him or bad results let's
say thanks for watching